you worked closely with Mark Zuckerberg
and Charles Sandberg what were those
people like Cheryl's leadership style
was unlike anything I'd seen before we
walked in a room it was a hang out with
a friend like she was just like okay
we're gonna do this this whatever and
like meeting's over in some way it was
like disarming but also effective Mark
that we were in a meeting and uh
somebody was giving a presentation it
was like a fairly big product decision
that we were trying to get his final
decision on in the middle of the
presentation he thought he said hey wait
a second go back one slide the color of
that button the shade of blue is off huh
that's looking like are we getting
punked right now how do you go from 10
000 feet down to like literally one inch
in the weeds and then back up to ten
thousand feet and the context switching
I was just blown away